Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Halime Ciewik und ich bin Ihre zustande geästen auf dieser Station und möchte Ihnen mit Ihnen dieses amamnese Gischöpfer durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Bevor Sie mir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden nennen, bräuchte ich ein paar persönliche Daten. Sie können jederzeit fragen, wenn etwas nicht klar ist. Also heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Marianne Spengermann. Ich bin eine Frau.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen bestabieren?
Ja, Marianne. Das schreibt sich M-A-R-I-A-N-N-E, Marianne. Dann Spengermann, S-P-E-N-G-E-M-A-N-N. Spengermann.
Spengermann. Frau Spengermann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 67 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 6. März 1957.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Zurzeit wiege ich 60 kg.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen, Frau Spengermann. Welche Beschwerden haben Sie? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, seit gestern, also seit einem Tag habe ich ziemlich starke Bauchschmerzen. Die werden eigentlich immer schlimmer.
Und deswegen muss ich jetzt zu Ihnen kommen. Sie müssen das dringend untersuchen. Solche starken Spiezen habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Sie haben gute Entscheidungen gemacht.
Seit gestern können Sie Bauchschmerzen genauer beschreiben. Wo tut es genau?
Es tut inzwischen der gesamte Bauchweh besonders, wahrscheinlich im linken Mittelbauch.
Links vom Bauchnabel, auf der linken Seite. Da ist es am schlimmsten.
Und ein bisschen im Unterbauch auf der linken Seite. Aber der ganze Bauch tut weh.
Besonders am linken Unterbauch.
Sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich auch getreten?
Nein, die haben langsam angefangen.
Bestellen die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder kommen und gehen Sie wieder?
Sie sind immer da, aber manchmal sind Sie ganz stark. Wie so eine Welle.
Und dann geht es wieder etwas zurück, aber die Schmerzen sind immer da.
Wie stark Ihre Schmerzen? Auch eine Schmerz, Karaphrone 0 bis 10.
Wobei 0 keine Schmerzen heißt und 10 sehr heftige Schmerzen entspricht.
Wie können Sie anbieten?
Sieben.
Wenn die Wellen kommen, verspülen Sie sieben?
Ja, dann sind Sie vielleicht sogar sieben bis acht.
Sagen wir zwischen sechs und acht?
Okay, aber immer da.
Und schützereländische Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
Nein.
Aber Sie verspülen die Schmerzen ganz in Bauch?
Ja, ganz in Bauch.
Okay.
Und haben Sie ein Auslöser bemerkt?
Frau Spengemann, zum Beispiel, wie Sie essen?
Kann ich mir nicht erklären. Ich habe keinen Auslöser bemerkt.
Okay. Was versteckt Ihre Schmerzen?
Ist Ihnen etwas gefallen?
Also, am liebsten lege ich mich ruhig hin auf den Rücken
und ziehe die Knie etwas an.
Das geht noch am besten.
Aber ich kann mich nicht groß bewegen oder herumlaufen.
Das geht nicht.
Mir ist auch sehr übel.
Jetzt habe ich aber auch erbrochen.
Okay, haben Sie schon einmal erbrochen?
Ja, einmal jetzt.
Vor ungefähr einer Stunde.
Vor einer Stunde.
Wie ist das erbrochen aus?
Erblich, schleimig.
Okay, das stimmt.
Und Sie haben schon erwähnt,
am liegen und Kniebeugen lindert Ihre Schmerzen.
Aber nur etwas?
Nur etwas.
Bei Bewegung verstehe ich der Schmerz.
Ja, ja.
Haben Sie Blut im Erbrochen gesehen?
Nein, Blut habe ich nicht gesehen.
Hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden früher oder ist das zum ersten Mal?
Solche Beschwerden habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Und sind Sie direkt zu uns zu kommen?
Oder haben Sie anderen Arztbesuch?
Nein, ich bin direkt jetzt zu Ihnen gekommen.
Okay.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen, Frau Spengemann?
Nein, bis jetzt habe ich nichts eingenommen.
Okay, verstehe.
Und leiden Sie auch unter Durchfall?
Nein, Durchfall habe ich nicht.
Ich habe sonst jeden Tag Stuhlgang.
Aber seit zwei Tagen habe ich gar keinen Stuhlgang.
Und vorher war der Stuhlgang,
in den Wochen vorher so ein bisschen auffällig,
weil er war manchmal, er war nicht so dick der Stuhlgang
und er war manchmal mit Schlein.
Hatte ich den Eindruck,
er war viel Schlein am Tourette-Papier.
Okay, normalerweise gehen Sie auf die Toilette,
Stuhlgang, jeden Tag, aber seit zwei Tagen haben Sie keinen Stuhlgang.
Ja, seit zwei Tagen kein Stuhlgang.
Er schleimt mich, aber haben Sie Blut gesehen?
Nein, er ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay, ich schleimte mich, ich könnte immer sagen.
Okay, leiden Sie unter Blähbauch oder Blähung gehen?
Nein, Blähungen habe ich nicht.
Aber der Bauch ist insgesamt, habe ich jetzt den Eindruck,
er ist dicker geworden seit gestern.
So, er hat sich so ganz fest und dick.
Okay, verstehe.
Jetzt haben Sie aktuell diese Schmerzen?
Ja.
Okay, und ich würde Ihnen empfehlen,
bis zum Ende dieses Gespräch,
dieses Gespräch, diese Schmerzen auszuhalten.
Wenn ich Ihnen einen Schmerzmittel geben,
diese Schmerzbewerke könnte Ihre Krankheitsbild verfälscht.
Genau, das habe ich auch gelesen
und deswegen habe ich jetzt auch noch kein Schmerzmittel genommen.
Okay, ja, das würde mich.
Und Herr Spengemann, fühlen Sie sich fieber?
Auch Spengemann, auch.
Ja, Entschuldigung.
Fühlen Sie sich fieber?
Nein, ich habe keinen Fieber, glaube ich nicht.
Haben Sie Schuhteprost oder Nachtschweiß?
Nachtschweiß habe ich in letzter Zeit vielleicht etwas häufiger gehabt.
Ich habe das immer auf das warme Wetter geschoben,
aber früher kannte ich das nicht.
Aber in letzter Zeit habe ich mehrfach so Nachtschweiß verspürt.
Wechseln Sie Ihre Kleidung?
Nein.
Ein bisschen Nachtschweiß.
Haben Sie Ihren Gewicht in der letzten Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Ich habe Gewicht abgenommen, so ungefähr 5 Kilo,
so innerhalb vielleicht von 2 Monaten.
2 Monaten, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist mein Appetit ganz gut,
aber seit gestern, seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe,
habe ich auch nichts gegessen, nur etwas getrunken.
Nicht gegessen, okay.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, ich habe mich noch nie gehabt.
Leiden Sie unter Husten oder Atemnot?
Ich bin gemahnt.
Seit der Kindheit habe ich ein allergisches Asthma.
Deswegen habe ich auch manchmal Husten und etwas Atemnot,
besonders im Frühjahr, wenn die Pollen fliegen.
Dann habe ich oft Husten und etwas Atemnot,
aber ich nehme dann Spreis und dann geht es ganz gut.
Ja, okay. Das ist nicht neu.
Für Ihre Beschwerden haben Sie.
Und schlafen Sie gut für das Spänkermann?
Normalerweise schlafe ich gut, ja.
Sondern seitdem ich jetzt in Rente bin,
dann schlafe ich gut her.
Verschwüren Sie Herzrasen?
Nein.
War Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, schwindelig ist mir auch nicht.
Okay, ja.
Und Fraschpänkermann,
haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches gegessen
oder haben Sie Schmerzen?
Nein, ich habe nichts Ungewöhnliches gegessen.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Ich war eine Woche lang auf Mallorca.
Das war im Mai.
Da war alles in Ordnung.
Nein, sonst war ich nicht im Ausland in letzter Zeit.
Das war im Mai.
Aber dann war ich nicht in der letzten Zeit.
Aber dann haben Sie wieder Schmerzen.
Fraschpänkermann, sind Sie in Wechseljahr?
Ja, ich bin in den Wechseljahren allein aufgrund meiner Operation.
Ich hatte eine Eierstockoperation vor sechs Jahren.
Eierstock, beide, Stöcke, beide.
Ja, ich hatte dabei keine Eierstockoperation.
Ich hatte keine Eierstockoperation.
Ich hatte keine Stöcke, beide vor derSONg
Ich hatte Eierstockkrebs.
Das musste operiert werden.
Ich bekam danach noch Mondayrapie.
Es war aber insgesamt die,
die Untersuchungen in Ordnung waren.
Ja, okay.
poreut nicht.
Ihre Chemotherapie auch beendet.
Ja. Okay. Und jetzt komme ich zu Ihrer Vorerkrankung.
Frau Spengemann, leiden Sie unter dauerhaften Erkrankungen?
Ja, einmal habe ich dieses Asthma.
Ergisches Asthma heißt es gegen Hausstaub, Hausstaub, Milbe und Pollen,
besonders im Frühjahr. Und dann nehme ich dann Sprehe.
Gehen Sie den Namen? Ja, das heißt Viany.
Welche Dosierung?
Nämlich zweimal am Tag dann. Aber jetzt im Augenblick nehme ich das nicht,
weil ich mit dem Augenblick keine Beschwerden.
Ich muss es meist im Winter nehmen und im Frühjahr.
Ja. Und dann habe ich noch eine Fruchtsucker-Unverträglichkeit seit 10 Jahren,
aber seitdem ich das weiß und eine Diätberatung hatte,
halte ich mich so vom Essen her danach und das geht gut.
Fruchtsucker. Ja, genau.
Vor sechs Jahren hatte ich dann den Eierstückkrebs.
Das war vor sechs Jahren.
Okay. Wie äußert sich die Fruchtsucker-Unverträglichkeit?
Fruchtsucker hatte ich damals, jetzt nicht mehr,
hatte ich damals Blähungen oft und Durchfälle und Bauchschmutzung.
Aber wie gesagt, jetzt meide ich stark fruchtzuckerhaltige Nahrungsmittel
und das geht.
Okay. Außer Asthma, haben Sie andere Vorerkrankungen? Keine.
Nein, ich bin mehrfach operiert worden.
Okay, dann einmal operiert worden und diese Spreie benutzen Sie,
ansonsten nehmen wir...
Operiert worden bin ich am Eierstück vor sechs Jahren
und vor 15 Jahren an der Galle.
Da wurde mir die Geilenblase entfernt,
weil ich Steine hatte und Koliken hatte.
Und als Kind, da war ich, glaube ich, so zehn Jahre alt,
da hatte ich einen Autorunfall und da hatte ich einen Milz-Riss.
Und da wurde die Milz entfernt.
Okay. Diese drei sind Ihre Voroperationen?
Ja. Ja. Ja.
Und dann nehmen Sie regelmäßig andere Medikamente, außer diese Spreie?
Nein, nur die Spreie.
Nur die Spreie, okay.
Vielen Dank, Frau Spengemann.
Und sind Sie vorständig geimpft?
Ja, also ich lasse das immer überprüfen.
Und jetzt im November bin ich angemeldet,
wieder zur Grippeimpfung und zur Covid-Impfung.
Der Impfstoff ist noch nicht da, der ist bestegelt
und ich stehe auf der Liste beim Hausarzt.
Sonst, sagt der Hausarzt, habe ich alle notwendigen Impfungen.
Das sei denn, ich will irgendwann mal eine Fernreise machen
nach irgendwo Asien oder so,
dann müsste ich noch andere Impfungen haben.
Aber das mache ich nicht, das will ich nicht.
Ich bleibe in Europa.
Ja, das ist super, Frau Spengemann.
Und jetzt komme ich zu Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Früher haben Sie geraucht?
Nein, noch nicht geraucht.
Das ist super. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke so gelegentlich ein Glas Wein.
Dann sind das in der Woche, also pro Woche,
ungefähr zwei bis drei Glas Wein pro Woche, aber nicht jeden Tag.
Pro Woche zwei, tak.
Zwei bis drei Glas Wein, ja, pro Woche.
Pro Woche, okay, zwei bis drei Glas, okay.
Nehmen Sie diese jetzt gefragt nicht persönlich,
das ist eine Rhythmusgefrage, konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Okay, ist gut.
Und jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Familien-Volkerkrankung
gerne sprähen.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, der Vater, der ist mit 69 Jahren verstorben
an eine Amdarmkrebs.
Und die Mutter, die Mutter, die lebt noch,
die ist 92 Jahre alt, die hat Alterszucker,
einen hohen Blutdruck
und die hat eine ziemlich starke Herzmuskelschwäche.
Dann nimmt sie auch viele Medikamente, aber es geht so.
Und Sie noch?
Ja, die Mutter lebt noch, die ist 92.
Eine Schwester, die ist 69 Jahre alt,
die hat eine chronische Nierenschwäche,
die muss dreimal pro Woche, muss sie zur Blutwäsche.
Okay, zweimal pro Woche?
Dreimal.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Frau Spengemann?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Wir haben zwei Kinder, die sind 38 Jahre alt und 35,
die sind gesund.
30 Jahre alt und 35.
38, 38 und 5.
Die sind gesund, okay.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Frau, Ihrer Mann?
Ja, ja.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie Rentnerin sind.
Was haben Sie Böreklüft davor gemacht?
Bis vor drei Jahren war ich Lehrerin.
Okay, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen, Frau Spengemann.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich frage Sie, was habe ich?
Was kann das sein?
Weil ich mache mir schon sehr große Sorgen,
weil meine Schmerzen sind zu stark und es geht mir ja nicht gut.
Ich verstehe Ihre Sorge für Frau Spengemann,
aber es ist zu früh etwas genauer zu sagen.
Ich brauche erst mal Sie körperlich untersuchen und Blut abnehmen,
dann gegebenenfalls Verfahren durchführen,
danach nach allen Ergebnissen kann ich Ihnen genauer sagen,
was Sie haben.
Ich werde Sie immer am laufenden Halten, okay.
Warten Sie bitte im Wartezimmer, ich rufe Sie gleich an.
Darf ich, wenn ich jetzt zwischendurch was Hunger haben sollte,
kann ich was essen oder was trinken?
Ja, ich würde Sie Ihnen empfehlen, nüchtern zu bleiben,
weil es könnte notfallmäßige Krankheiten sein,
deswegen, da bleiben wir besser.
Okay, gut, dann machen wir das so.
Dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit, sich vorzubereiten,
auch die Vorstellung dann beim Oberarzt
und vielleicht die anderen Kolleginnen und Kollegen,
die zugehört haben, haben vielleicht Fragen oder Erginzungen.
Ja.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ich glaube, dass nicht.
Haben Sie ein Bleistiftstuhl bemerkt?
Bleistiftstuhl, was heißt Bleistiftstuhl?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Ja, dünnestuhl.
Ja, das habe ich, glaube ich, gesagt,
ich habe bemerkt in den letzten Wochen,
dass das Bleistiftstuhl insgesamt nicht mehr so dick ist,
sondern so dünner ist, also wie ein Bleistift kann sein.
Ja, ja.
Okay, danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Waren Sie schon mal beim Hausarzt
für Darmkrebsvorsorge?
Ich habe, das war,
weil mein Vater ja auch am Darmkrebs verstorben ist,
habe ich mal eine Darmspiegelung machen lassen,
das war, als ich den Eierstockkrebs hatte vor sechs Jahren.
Da ist eine Darmspiegelung gemacht worden.
Da war aber alles in Ordnung.
Das war vor sechs Jahren im Rahmen,
glaube ich, das war im Rahmen der, vor der Operation,
als da wurde alles durch untersucht.
Ja, okay.
Die zweite Frage ist,
hatten Sie in den letzten zwei Tagen,
bin Sie rausgekommen von Aftar?
Nein, nein.
Okay, danke.
Das war realistisch.
Ja.
Eine wichtige Frage.
Ich denke, können Sie sich mal genau beschreiben,
sind Sie ja dumm versteckt,
und so weiter.
Ja, Sie sind ja so, ja, so wellenförmig,
Trumpfartig.
Meistens ist es ein dumpfer Schmerz.
Nur wenn es sich so verstärkt wie eine Welle,
dann wird es auch eher so stechend.
Aber meistens ist der Schmerz dumpf.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind hervorragend.
Können wir jetzt beginnen?
Der Oberarzt ist immer bereit.
Okay.
Schönen Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute mit einem neuen Patienten
das Anamnese-Gespräch geführt
und Ihnen den Fall vorstellen.
Mit einer neuen Patientin, Patientin,
Frau Spenem.
Ja, das ist schwer,
weil sie sehen mich als Mann,
als Frau, als ich sie habe gesagt.
Ja, ich habe heute mit einer neuen Patientin
das Anamnese-Gespräch geführt
und möchte Ihnen den Fall vorstellen.
Ich habe gut gesagt, okay.
Es handelt sich Marianne Spengemann.
Sie sei 67 Jahre alt,
am 6.03.1957 geboren.
1,68 m groß und 60 kg schwer.
Herr Spengemann,
ich stelle dich heute
wegen seit gestern 5 Jahren
chronisch aufgetretener,
progressierender, diffuser
und wellenförmiger,
so wie krampfartiger und dumpfer
Bauchschmerzen bei uns vor.
Die Schmerzen seien
erst am linken Unterbauch,
aber sie berichtete,
dass die Schmerzen diffuser sind.
Sie ordnet die Schmerzen
auf einer Schmerzskala von null bis zehn
ohne Wellen 6 und bei Wellen 8 ein.
Der Schmerz habe keine Ausstrahlung
und keine Auslösung.
Der Schmerz versteckt sich
bei Bewegung und lindert sich
am Ligen und Kniebeugen.
Außerdem leidet die Patienten
Ausbegleitsymptome unter Nausea.
Und Emesis, einmalige Emesis
mit gelblichem, schleimigem,
ohneglutigem Erbrochen.
Und das war vor einer Stunde.
Und als Begleitsymptome nannte
die Patienten auch
Defekationveränderungen.
Die Stuhl sei dünner geworden
in der letzten Zeit.
Und auch keine Flatulenz
hat die Patienten.
Und die Fragen nach
vorheriger Arztbesuch
und früheren beschwerden
Methodismus
und wurden fernleinend.
Die vegetative Annamenase zeigt sich
Gewicht, Abnahme 5 Kilo
innerhalb zwei Monaten.
Und Inappetenz seit gestern.
Die Patienten habe keine gegessen.
Und normalerweise habe die Patienten
jeden Tag Defekation.
Aber seit zwei Tagen
habe sie keine und dünne Stuhl.
Und in der vegetative Annamenase
gab es noch Düsne
und Husten wegen Asthma.
Ja, die Reise Annamenase
sei die Patienten vor
fünf Monaten, eine Woche
auf der Mallorca.
Und aus Vorerkrankungen
seien bei der Patienten Asthma
gegen Hausstaub und Polenallergie
und Arztbesuch
ein allergisches Asthma-Brontiale
gegen Hausstaub und Polen
oder vor Greif, Polenbrühe.
Und als Voroperation nannte die
Patienten
die Ferectomy vor sechs Jahren
wegen
O-Verealkarzinom.
Und vor 15 Jahren eine Holististik-Tomy.
Und als Kindheit
wegen eines Autounfalles
Splenektomie.
Die Medikamente-Annamenase
ergab die Inhalation von
Viami zwei Mal pro Tag.
Besonders im Winter und Frühjahr
gegen allergische Asthma.
Das Mittel heißt Viani.
Viani.
Okay.
Bei der Patienten
sei Fruchtzucker-Intoleranz bekannt.
Die
Methorismus und Diarrheuse
im Status sei vollständig.
Auch Kindheit,
gegen Kindheitskrankheiten, auch Covid und Grippe.
Und die Patienten
sei nicht raucherin.
Und die Trinke gelegentlich
zwei bis drei Gläserweinen
pro Woche.
Der Drogengesum wurde verneint.
In der Familienannamenase
sei der Vater
mit 69 Jahren
an Kolonkarkzinom verstorben.
Die Mutter lebt
Leben noch und leide an Diabetes-Militus
und Arterialhypertoni
und Herzinsubizienz.
Myocardinsubizienz.
Und die Schwester leide
chronische Nährung insubizienz.
Und ...
Sie könnten eigentlich die Prüfung morgen machen.
Brauchen Sie nicht anderthalb Monate warten.
Denken Sie daran,
Sie haben das sehr gut dargestellt.
Auch gut mit den Fachbegriffen.
Den einzigen Fachbegriff, den ich noch hätte,
wäre gerne nicht, dass Sie sagen Bauchschmerzen,
sondern dass Sie sagen abdominelle Schmerzen.
Bauchschmerzen, abdominelle Schmerzen.
Ansonsten habe ich nichts zu kritisieren.
Das fand ich sehr gut.
Und Sie haben das sehr ruhig gemacht.
Und auch systematisch.
Sie haben eigentlich kaum was vergessen.
Nicht wesentlich was vergessen.
Sonst hätten die Kollegen noch viel mehr gefragt.
Vorbeugelt untersuchungen habe ich von Ihnen
vielmals gehört und zu gehört auch etwas vergessen.
Ja, also das, wie gesagt,
da wäre ich als Prüfer sehr zufrieden mit Ihnen.
Sie haben mich gefragt mit den Schmerzmitteln.
Wer gelährt, weshalb Sie jetzt kein Schmerzmittel geben.
Deshalb Sie darauf erstmal verzichten wollen.
Das ist, denke ich, eine wichtige Information
für einen Patienten, der starke Schmerzen hat jetzt.
Sie können es ja anbieten.
Aber gut, ich finde sehr gut.
Der Moderator findet das auch sehr gut.
Danke.
Ja, ich finde sehr gut.
Ja, okay.
Ich glaube, die Zeit, ich habe jetzt gar keine Uhr hier.
Aber die Zeit ist, glaube ich, langsam rumdenken Sie daran.
Sie haben nur 20 Minuten Zeit für die Anamnese.
Dass Sie das gut organisieren für sich in Ihrem Zeitplan.
Sie haben dann mehr Vorbereitung zwar,
aber denken Sie daran, dass Sie die 20 Minuten möglichst einhalten
und nicht am Ende plötzlich irgendwie etwas
im Express-Tempo machen müssen.
Aber so finde ich, dass Sie das gut organisieren.
Das ist das, was ich mir auch schon gesagt habe.
Ich bin froh, dass Sie das gut organisieren.
Aber so finde ich, könnten Sie Morgenprüfung machen.
Und ich bin davon überzeugt, dass Sie die auch gut bestehen.
Ich hoffe, vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank.